إنها مدينة يثير اسمها ادعاءات غامضة
بالتستر والعذاب والعودة إلى هذا المركز الأصلي
لتفشي فيروس كورونا
في 23 يناير 2020 ، هذه المدينة التي تضم
أكثر من 11 مليون ساكن
مغلقين عليها قبل ساعات من
بدء  ظل الحجر الصحي لمدة أسبوع في
بكين
لمدة 76 يومًا مغلقًا
، وها نحن نعود مرة أخرى بعد عام واحد ،
كان سوق جوانان للمأكولات البحرية
يعتقد
أن السلطات الصينية كانت نقطة البداية
لهذا التفشي هذا
الوقت من العام الماضي.
بعيدًا في غضون دقائق من الإبلاغ
الآن في يناير 2021 ،
لا يوجد أمن هنا ، لقد
تجولنا لعدة دقائق ، ولا
يبدو أنهم مهتمون
بذلك حتى بدأنا في البحث في الداخل ،
لاحظنا أن بعض الأشخاص يعملون
خلف البوابة
فجأة يبدو أنهم عابرون عشوائيًا على
دراجة  صرخ
فينا قائلاً لا تكن متسترًا ، فقد
عرّف عن نفسه لاحقًا
بشكل غامض على أنه يعمل لصالح الحكومة
وأخبرنا أن نتجول ونحاول الدخول.
يمكننا أن نسير بهذه الطريقة ، قال على ما يبدو أنه
يمكننا الدخول لذلك سنرى ما إذا كان بإمكاننا
الدخول بالفعل إلى السوق ، لكنني
سأطلب من هذا الرجل ،
هل يمكنك الدخول ، لا يمكنك الدخول إلى الداخل ،
أخبرهم أننا  لديك اختبار covent ،
اختبار covid سلبي ،
حسنًا ، أنت فقط لا نلعبه جيدًا ،
لا تأخذ
ذلك بوضوح شديد الحساسية بعض الشيء ، ربما
لأننا أجانب أو لأننا
صحفيون ، أصبح أصل الفيروس مسيّسًا بدرجة كبيرة
ويتهم المسؤولون الأمريكيون  الصين
من التستر والسماح للفيروس
بنشر
الصين دفاعية ، قائلة إن إدارة ترامب
كانت
تلوم على سوء تعاملها مع
فريق من الأشخاص المكلفين الآن
بمحاولة اكتشاف
الحقيقة ومع ذلك ، وبغض النظر
عن المعاناة الإنسانية ، فهي عالمية.
تحدث معنا الشباب وهم يعلمون أنها
قد تواجه ضغوطًا من المسؤولين ،
لكن الأم التي فقدت ابنتها الوحيدة
ليس لديها المزيد لتخسره
عندما جلست ، لقد شكرتني
على الكشف عن الحقيقة
كما تعرفها
لأن  لم يخبرنا المسؤولون المحليون
عن الأوبئة ، فقالت إنه
إذا تم اتخاذ إجراءات لما كنت
سأرسل طفلي إلى المستشفى
الذي كان مصدر العدوى
في كانون الثاني (يناير) الماضي ، كانت ابنة شابة تبلغ من العمر 24 عامًا
تتلقى العلاج من السرطان
الذي أصيبت به تشتهي 19 و  توفيت في
أوائل فبراير
عندما أتحدث عن هذا ،
قالت لي هذه المرأة التي تبيع قصب السكر
في خضم الألم العميق الذي واجهناه أيضًا في
لحظات من الأمل في عودتنا
عشية الإغلاق العام الماضي ،
زرنا سوق الفاكهة
هذا.
في الوقت الذي شعرت فيه بالرعب
، بقيت تخشى العبء المالي بعد
12 شهرًا ،
التقينا مرة أخرى في ذلك الوقت ، كنت أبكي
طوال الوقت أخبرتني أننا
نعاني ونخاف
فوق قناع وجهها ، ما زال الألم
واضحًا في عينيها.
يتسم سكان روهان
بالمرونة في تشبيههم بالأبطال ،
ويسعدني جدًا أن أراكم شخصيًا وأن
أعرف أنك
تجاوزت فترة الإغلاق وأنت بصحة جيدة
، حيث انتقل السوق إلى  يختلف بشكل ملحوظ
عن العام الماضي في
الأعمال الصاخبة للأشخاص الذين يشعرون براحة أكبر ،
هل يمكنك القول إن ووهان عاد
مفتوحًا وفي طريقه إلى التعافي ،
لم يبدأ الأمر من الآن فقط ،
فهو يقول إنه بدأ مبكرًا جدًا
لأكون صادقًا في رأيي ، لقد
بدأ ووهان بالفعل في التعافي منذ ذلك الحين  أصبح سائق التوصيل في منتصف مارس إلى أواخر مارس
معروفًا جيدًا على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي الصينية
حيث قام بتأريخ الحياة خلال فترة
الإغلاق في ذلك الوقت
، وهو الآن يضرب مدينة مقفرة
وسط الإغلاق
تلاه صيف مليء
بصور حفلات البلياردو التي صدمت عالمًا بعيدًا اجتماعيًا في
الخارج  من الصين والاحتفال بالعام الجديد
الذي جلب سكان ووهان
جنبًا إلى جنب على الرغم من
تفشي المرض العنقودي الجديد في شمال الصين ،
يرتدي الكثيرون هنا في ووهان مرة أخرى
أقنعة للوجه
حذرًا من المجهول العالق وما
زالوا محاطين
بذكريات مؤلمة من الإغلاق
الذي أبقى  أغلق الملايين من السكان
مع حزنهم
بالداخل لبعضهم الآن فقط بعد 12
شهرًا
، لقد بدأ للتو  نينغ إلى السطح ديفيد
غطاء CNN